[Musique]
l'utilisation récente de chiens
d'assistance pour les diabétiques repose
sur le dorat unique de ces animaux de
compagnie une partie de l'air inspiré
est envoyé vers les voies respiratoires
le reste se dirige au fond du museau
dans une cavité dédié à leur faction
quand la chienne expire l'air ressort
des poumons mais celui qui circule dans
la cavité nasale reste en place
elle peut donc aspirer de nouvelles
molécules pour les concentrés et mieux
les identifier la surface de sa cavité
nasale est environ 15 fois plus grande
que la nôtre
les millions de récepteurs qui l'a
tapissent achemine l'information
jusqu'au bulbe olfactif lui aussi
nettement plus important que chez
l'humain c'est ce qui rend son flair si
exceptionnel
[Musique]